one of the first things you learn in
therapy if you do go to therapy is like
your inner child still lives oh yeah
it sounded like such a weird like campy
strange thing to do to like talk to it
and like you know nurture it but i found
myself being so emotional doing that
like i've had sessions where like i've
talked to myself as a kid and i didn't
know why i would get so emotional about
it but you realize like how much
there is that innocent kid in there that
just wants to be loved and nurtured and
is so scared you know
i just was
like what if i
decided to do with my life talk about
your inner child i reached out to my
nine-year-old inner child was like you
were
really off the mark lady like why did
you want to be an actress this was a
stupid idea and she's like she would
have been an archaeologist like you
thought yes i wanted to be an
archaeologist before that you should
have been an archaeologist damn it um
my nine-year-old self was like you'll
catch up
stupid girl my nine-year-old self is way
wiser than me
um
but so our inner child is always super
wise very simple very clear but usually
very wise extremely wise i defer to her
at all at all times at all costs like
it's just like where are you please help
but so does your inner child have a name
have you given your inner child name
little anna i call it a little little
anna um because i'm anna lynn and i have
this photo i don't know if you'll have
if this is a practice that one of your
therapists ever do with you
i have this photo i have this photo on
my phone can you guess okay
can you guess what this photo is that
i've had since
january i know maybe your inner child
see you as a kid
it's me as a kid
i definitely did some of that when i was
um
fighting anorexia you know something i
went through in my late teens early 20s
and that was i think one one of the
really helpful techniques was just
talking to the inner child it's so much
easier to love yourself when you think
of yourself as a little girl whose body
i'm hurting
you know and
looking at her and being like she was
perfect you know there was nothing wrong
with her and like it kind of helps you
humanize yourself you know the degree to
which you have learned in yourself just
by virtue of maybe being in an
environment as a child that like okay i
don't want to do anything to rock the
boat
i don't want to upset anyone i don't
want to do anything wrong i don't want
to be a bad girl these are all very
common narratives for children that
nonetheless manifest in adults where it
becomes a mechanism for
self-preservation so
your self-reflection which we could say
is beautiful and it really is really
speaks to me in a way that it shows that
you perhaps have become a little bit too
responsible in the way that you think
you're accountable for other people's
wellness or their happiness or
100 accurate can you share how does that
leave you feeling i'm abandoning really
the inner child but i'm wondering what
that dialogue's been like with your
inner child and if it's changed
um i was like super not in touch with it
like for a long long time again like i
just kind of got through things by like
suppressing and suppressing and just
being like oh that's not attached to
this or that's fine like you know i just
kind of always like pushed it down so i
feel like there was no dialogue at all
like i just like pushed her down
completely
um and yeah it was just never something
that like i just always thought you know
like
you grow up and life changes and that's
it and you don't realize how much
you are affected by things when you're
younger and how much that innocence is
still
in you like ultimately yeah we're grown
up and we have you know new views and
you know new experiences but ultimately
like all we are is just like
children and innocent
people just that want to be loved and
want companionship and want to be
understood and
so i think that dialogue has changed
completely with not only the way i speak
to my inner child per se but just the
way i speak to myself now
um you know it's the same thing i mean
it's essentially the same thing 100 yeah
it's just a part of you it's just that
innocent
part of you that's just trying to
navigate life that you know just trying
to understand my inner child when i met
her and she was running from me one of
the things that began to build the trust
was i went back into all the memories
that i had the memories that weren't
fragmented the ones that i actually had
that were not so wonderful and i had
plenty of not so wonderful memories on
that i didn't remember i closed my eyes
and i imagined myself and then i was
like you know what i'm going to have a
few more anilins i decided to bring an
army of anilines 32 anilins geared up
and we stormed into those memories and i
got my little self out of those memories
i picked her up told anyone who was
hurting her you want to [ __ ] come at
us because we'll rip your face off and
and i came out with this mama bear
protective love energy
and that was how it began and i started
to gain her trust this is a photo i've
had
since january
and my qt
and my therapist was like
listening and i said why do i keep
choosing specific types of relationships
right
now these not that these people are bad
and wrong not that you know
nothing just not the right match for me
right and there was um
i kept doing it because i kept
abandoning myself i kept abandoning
myself on my values and my vision to
create peace and make someone else happy
as opposed to
being peace and healing that i am not
enough inner child wounds
to creating boundaries
and then creating from a place of
standards and agreements not i'm
constantly having my agreements broken
by a partner and giving in to try to
make them happy to create peace so even
if you were to look at a third person if
you were to abandon someone that you
loved if you abandoned a daughter a
child how would that feel for you i'm
just being honest like i
don't wouldn't do that you said it
perfectly i've abandoned myself in the
process of trying to protect myself it
looks like i'm being more considerate of
the other person which is actually about
self-preservation going back to the
child that didn't want to get in trouble
didn't want to upset mom whatever it is
and so actually you're abandoning your
own self
in the process of self survival now once
you see that there's got to be some
feeling of something i got a dog in the
pandemic as a lot of us did i you know
got a coveted puppy and it wasn't like
it kind of clicked for me when i would
like
look at her even now i look at her and
i'm like look at this like little being
this poor little thing just like relies
on me for
you know like for
simple things like food water love like
to be nurtured like if i neglected this
little dog like she would not survive in
the world like she relies on me so
heavily i would i would like never do
anything to harm this little being but
then i was looking at how i treat myself
and i'm like some days like i don't eat
because i'd be so depressed like i'd be
too depressed to eat i wouldn't feed
myself i wouldn't sleep
i wouldn't like i'd talk to myself
horribly i would do everything that i
would never do to this little being that
i love so much and i'm like how do i do
it to myself then like why do i deserve
the things that
like someone else would never deserve
you know and that's when it really
clicked i'm like why am i not treating
myself with the same care with the same
level of love and patience and care and
honestly that's when it clicked like i
have to start treating myself as if i
were treating like my dog or like a baby
you know or like someone that i love
um because we always tend to get the
brunt of our
our own judgment you know and oftentimes
the way that we speak to ourselves never
how we would speak to to someone we love
you know so that's honestly when it
clicked is when i was started caring for
someone
else you know for this little thing this
little tiny
bundle of love you know i was intent on
my inner child trusting me and not
running from me anymore in my mind and i
didn't care how i got there so i created
this army inside my mind and i would go
in and i would imagine the bad memory i
would walk up the street i would i would
literally like see myself in my army of
aniline strutting down the street turn
down the driveway fling open the door
and like hey [ __ ]
we're about to throw down right now and
i was like i and it was amazing because
my mind would play with me and and i i
had one moment where
my little self i had gotten good at this
so now i was like oh now i know what to
do just come in like you know
beat some face get my little self out
we're good you know and then i had one
memory where i couldn't get little me
out
and that's when i realized that my mind
was actually
playing back with me but i was not in
control of it
and this was a little this was both
enlightening and terrifying so what i
did was exactly what i'd done with all
these other memories and i always was
able to pick her up and we leave the
memory and and then i in my mind i felt
like that i had
taken that moment and healed it because
i got her out and i made her safe i
became the woman that my little me
needed and i showed up for her and in
time and space in my brain i was able to
make those moments happen and heal those
spots well then i had this memory and i
go to pick up my little self just like
normal and i'm like okay out of here
let's fly girl and she drops like lead
to the ground
and i and i see the person who's coming
to sexually abuse her and it's not the
one who is normally perpetrating onto
her someone else
and i'm i'm seeing him getting closer
and i'm like no like i'm i'm gonna i'm
gonna kick this guy's at like no you
have to like we gotta get out of here
like i started getting frantic in my own
mind at a situation that was just in my
own mind but i but it felt so real and i
didn't know why i couldn't get her out
and i all of a sudden i said i need to
trust my mind our bodies want to heal
themselves right i always use the
example of you gotta cut on your arm you
don't have to be like coagulate blood
scab overs
new skin grow you know the body's like
um lady i got this the mind is the same
way just create a safe clean environment
a safe clean space for the wound to heal
same in the mind when i opened up and
said please help me get her out of here
i was able to find a way to to
utilize the the people in my spouse i
started bringing in other people other
sources i brought in
a child version
of one of the perpetrators who i loved
who was someone in the community
and
before he was abused i i my mind went
back and got him
at eight years old i don't know i
wouldn't know to think to do this my
mind did this by itself
and it was literally like i was watching
a movie now in my own mind and it's like
shit's going down and i'm like i'm not
in control
but this this little boy version of this
person who grows up to be someone that i
love to then when i'm 31 remember that
he harmed me he he opens the door to the
shed he dives in
and runs he starts crying
dives to the ground and picks up little
me we're about the same age about the
same size at that point he's like
somebody help her somebody please help
her she needs help she's hurting
i was i literally came out of the emdr
session with my doctor and i started
bawling my eyes out and i was like
i started learning compassion i started
learning all of these tools all of these
techniques we talked about alchemy at
the beginning of the conversation this
was how i learned to alchemize
my trauma because because that was the
same boy who would grow up and harm me
later but in this memory he was
he was good
i would say well
well we've created this incredible
dynamic and connection and had these fun
times so i'm just going to do whatever
it takes to make you happy to make this
work
and that was all that was my lesson to
learn how to walk away when something
wasn't in alignment with my higher self
and so this has been a profound year
of
continued healing of the you know my
little louis who
i abandoned for 30 plus years
to create peace
to try to make someone happy with who i
was and change myself to please them the
way i watched my mom do that with my dad
i cried so much for my inner child like
i would literally like hug myself i did
the same i did this
did you hug your i didn't actually
myself
i did an exercise one time that made me
weep like a child where
i was laying i first did wim hof
and started breathing and like just
channeling it and moving the energy
throughout my body
and then i was meditating afterwards and
i did an ex exercise where
i was laying down
and um
i would see my five-year-old self that
was sexually abused
and i was holding my five-year-old self
and then i had a moment where i was
having a conversation
with my five-year-old self saying
i got you like we're here now
and then i like immersed i like put him
into me i was like hugging myself just
like that it was
crazy crazy experiences i feel like i
believe in all of the above that you
mentioned i believe in the inner child
like trusting that truest form of
yourself
because i think that's the closest
you'll ever get to like your spirit your
own spirit is that like sweet inner
child so i believe in all of it when you
really wake up and go wow i have truly
because without going through every item
of your romantic relationships and where
there was hostility or there was
hardship or there was you know
derogatory ex at your expense
you know there was abuse of some form
and abuse is a big word but like it
could be the way someone spoke to you
like that's the abandonment of yourself
um
this is the process of
healing to be able to feel for the
abandoned child abandoned inner self yes
the inner child yeah like if i'm if
that's if being that way
and i said it's a i feel like that'd be
abandoning yeah what would it feel like
to abandon someone you're asking that if
i could create understand that feeling
if i could start to access that feeling
i would now
create the relationship with the inner
child because that's exactly what i've
done to it yes
and it gets a little deeper because
you're also the inner child so there's
not only the experience of a woman who
is denying her own needs her own worth
the way that people treat her which is
the abandonment of self but there's the
experience of that which is abandoned
within you
when you recognize that you have
feelings right and i'm not talking in a
woo-woo kind of kumbaya but you're a
sentient being you're a woman you know
an extraordinary woman and an
accomplished woman and a caring woman
and the degree to which all of that gets
kind of pushed to one side because you
can handle the abuse as i tell people
just because it's familiar doesn't mean
it's healthy right
totally yeah so so can you just even if
it's a word or two if you recognize the
degree to which you've discarded some of
your own
like
care of self
what would that leave you feeling it
would be like i've disassociated with
myself and so it feels that's why it's
so hurtful because that's exactly what i
do to myself whatever your best is be
kind to yourself i learned kindness to
my inner child i learned compassion i
learned kindness and compassion and if
we looked around at 7.8 billion people
in the world and instead we saw 7.8
billion inner children in the world
we would be a lot kinder
but you've learned to protect yourself
and be okay with it even though you're
not actually okay with it energetically
and physiologically it will manifest in
different ways over time you know you're
still young and healthy but over time
that's what becomes dis-ease
you know manifest physiologically
because of the absence of ease in our
system because we're actually hurt and
hurts bedfellow is also fear scared yeah
so that little girl who's protected
herself by virtue of becoming tough and
resilient is actually hurt and scared oh
no i'm gonna cry on you yeah it's
beautiful but it was like
i was like wow
this is the wound like i've had to have
my own back
my whole life
[Music]